okay the david pakman show subreddit
continues to grow
it's now up to nearly 8 000 or so
subscribers uh 7 700 to be exact i was
browsing some of the discussions this
morning and a few things caught my eye
that i wanted to mention to you
first and foremost there was a thread
about uh
my sort of twitter exchange with stefan
molyneux which i talked about yesterday
and it references something i also
mentioned which is
an argument that quote it's a mistake to
call white supremacist white supremacist
you got to get smart people be one step
ahead of them
and call them white nationalists or
simply
racists and the poster who goes by the
name john rawls
makes the case that david made this
school boy error
when he confronted molyneux on twitter
david should have known
better and come prepared maloney is not
illiterate david should have anticipated
the i'm not a white supremacist
because i think asians are smarter than
whites rebuttal
now i know that argument is fallacious
because one can be a white supremacist
these are the other races in this
context africans and blacks
i mean molyneux is clearly a white
supremacist vis-a-vis
black people he believes whites are
superior to blacks that's obvious
however as a self-proclaimed empiricist
he also knows that east asians score
higher on intelligence tests than whites
so when you accuse him of being a white
supremacist he and others will say
actually i think asians are smarter than
whites so to preempt this
call them white nationalists or racists
and then when they say how you simply
say
this is the dictionary definition of
racist or white nationalist
i i did mention this yesterday pat and i
sort of recognized it as a mistake
but at the same time you know it's not
as though if i said white nationalist
everybody would say you know what david
you're right he would just come up with
something else but i do
think that the term white supremacist
while accurate
does open the door to some of these
defenses like really i'm an asian
supremacist because i think
asians are the smartest yeah i tend to
just roll my eyes at these semantics
conversations but i think he makes some
good points there may be calling them
white nationalists is more accurate and
you can
preempt some of their counterpoints that
way
and with with molineux specifically i
mean he was talking about how great
the white nation of poland was how in
poland everybody's white and you don't
have political correctness he doesn't
need security as his event
at his events and all of this other
stuff so in a sense it may even be more
accurate
also from the david pakman show
subreddit i spotted a discussion about
my commentary
on a george h w bush and uh user
uh ho 231 says pacman tells the whole
truth
about george h w bush unlike the
mainstream media's glorification of the
late former president
we should not ignore the whole story
thanks for keeping it real
david yeah i i don't know pat that i
really did anything
that um that incredible
in a sense i mean what what i pointed
out was that
we can recognize the
sadness of people losing a family member
and we don't wish for people to die but
we don't have to sugarcoat their
political record because people are
people and they're also elected
officials and i think that
i mean i it's me saying it so i don't
think people will be surprised but
any responsible coverage of someone
involved in politics for as long as
george h.w bush was involved in politics
would offer some kind of critique of
what they achieved or did as an elected
official that we would hope that all
media would do that unfortunately they
don't
yeah maybe that's what you're trying to
do balance some of that out because
after someone dies
you typically just want to praise them
and it's important to also make sure
that you take that sort of
adversarial approach and i think we kind
of provided that balance
someone wrote to me and said david what
you don't understand is
people feel good when they just watch
the funeral
and pretend everybody gets along
although not everybody did get along at
the funeral i'll have video of of that
for you later
and we see the clintons and the obamas
and the bushes and the carters
hanging out and they all get along
notice i'm not mentioning the current
president in that because he didn't seem
to be getting along with them
people like the songs and all of the
stuff
people just feel good and there's so
much in the world right now that people
feel bad about that
let them have their thing and you know
what i think that that's totally fine
the funeral itself is just a ceremony
for someone who has been involved with
their country george h.w bush
for decades and decades and decades and
is part of a family that has been
involved in politics for that long
i think that it's reasonable pat not to
do the political stuff
at the funeral or during coverage of the
funeral but in coverage of the life of
george w bush i think it's irresponsible
not to mention the political disasters
that the guy was responsible for yeah
not none of us are perfect right and you
have to be able to from a media
standpoint
weigh the positives and negatives of
someone's life of someone's
administration
and that's what we're trying to do and
these aren't attacks
these shouldn't be seen as you know
whatever i think you most of you get it
and we'll deal with the usps closure
in light of george w but george h.w
bush's
funeral um a little bit later on in the
program as well join the discussion it's
respectful i promise we have moderators
nearly 8 000 of our viewers and
listeners regularly
discuss politics on our subreddit
at davidpakman.com slash r-e-d-d-i-t